come back to GameSpot's continuing
coverage of e3 2014 we've had new games
we've had all games and now we have a
new game of perhaps the oldest and most
classic video game of all time I'm so
happy to be joined by alexey pajitnov
how you doing sir Hank hey the creators
of Tetris massive amazing to have Hank
Rogers Lexi here and of course Agee from
Ubisoft okay it's not that we don't love
you but but it's just having these guys
here is pretty great underneath this is
what it is it's about the old and the
new we have the creators of Tetris just
stick in the feet up here just being
nice and relaxed in a Dutch style and
then of course we've got Tetris ultimate
coming at first of all I want to talk to
you Alexei and Hank about Tetris how
many years has been since that just came
out pop quiz we celebrate dizzy
anniversary now okay so you know every
single time when was the last time you
were at e3 when was the last time you
were at any 30 about six years ago has
it changed much something changed but
something remain absolutely the same
watched us the game some kind of
old-fashioned boozes okay yeah fair
enough what about yourself Hank I still
see lots and lots of beautiful girls at
e3 they said they're not supposed to
have booth babes anymore but they're
everywhere yeah two years ago they said
no more booth babes really well I wasn't
talking about the booth babes okay but
still I just want to make a point of it
there are booth babes like I don't you
know apparently it's okay if they're a
DJ or something I don't know we'll see
what happens and can we talk a little
you're probably sick of telling the
story but can he tell the story you've
had the two of you mesh because
obviously you created Tetris you're
responsible for bringing Tetris onto the
home consoles and how would headed back
home embarrass how did you guys meet so
this it's 1989 februari end of februari
it's freezing cold I'm in Moscow I'm
looking for the ministry of software
okay and I finally managed to hire an
interpreter and she took me to the door
she said I'm not going in with you
because you're not invited so what do
you mean I'm not invited I'm not invited
well I said I'm gonna walk
his door anyway so I walked in and I was
surrounded by people I said I'm looking
for somebody who can talk to me about
this game the game I held in my hand was
Tetris little old guy comes down the
stairs I say okay I want to meet people
tomorrow and talk about Tetris because I
figured they need to assemble the people
in the room yeah sure n Alexi was there
in that room with nine other people KGB
types business dev types all kinds and
then I guess that's it it's almost a
story like worthy of phila mode how it
came out the trouble that was and it's
like a room full of people who knew
nothing and Alexei Alexei and I were
game designers so we could talk to each
other and we became friends right away
everybody else in the room had no idea
what we're talking about so you know
intellectual property didn't exist in
the Soviet Union course yeah yeah and so
basically I had to walk them through it
you know what is it that they're
supposed to license to me how they're
supposed to how does it work they wanted
to know all about my business it was
very exciting because they just told me
when I was in the lobby the day before
that they had never given the nintendo
rights to anyone Ohio really and I'm
saying I've got two hundred thousand
cartridges in manufacture and I'm like
going holy blank you can say it I got
your feet up on the table all right
hello only very well hey I am in such
deep kimchi it's not even funny and so
but I focused I said listen today I'm
here to get the gameboy rights and I'll
figure out the other stuff afterwards
and that was a good idea excellent Alex
did you think there's over 30 years ago
that you'd be sitting here in 2014 with
a new version of Tetris for for the
people who played it before and for new
folks as well well I thought why not I'm
I'm actually surprised that lots of game
I loved that time are dead already i
don't know why it should sue it should
leave it should be the here for us
because you know platforms change all
the time but our brain is still
they're true and they don't change that
fast so what we enjoy before we should
enjoy now Adrian you're part of the team
responsible for developing this new
version Tetris ultimate and can you just
give a sort of an overview as to what it
what about it is a shadow of the former
game and one on what's new because this
coming over like current gen ps4 and
Xbox is also yeah we're doing we're
doing a version on PS playstation 4 xbox
one it's coming out this summer we've
taken the best mode from the last 30
years that people enjoy the most and we
try to put our spin on that nine tails
you've been able to play cooperatively
team vs vs online offline against AI so
and you know trying to make this really
social as well so you know we're friends
which I we will being one you know I can
see how you played that game i can see
your high score and i can go and beat
that so we're trying to do as much as
hot as we can with the current tech that
we've got available right now you try to
do as much as you can Oh absolute Texas
we had a current tech absolutely love it
and I love it out all right dear your
ideas for tetris are so crazy upsetting
even the PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
whenever I like the guys is that it 60
frames per second at 1080p yes amazing
Alexei can I get you to say to the
camera it'll be in 60 frames per second
1080p what say what it's in 60 frames
per second it's in 60 frames per second
and 1080p and a 10 10 10 80 AD IE p I'm
sorry p I'm from Ireland hey PA doesn't
come it doesn't come on down AGP 1080p
good and what are the types of features
are you going to lean into the
multiplayer stuff because Tetris is one
of those games that was very much a you
versus your minds why was you trying to
make yourself smarter trying to figure
out the game we still got that and
that's like how most people are going to
play this but we also got very heavy
multiplayer component in this right so
you know using use it using the friends
list on on first parties and stuff like
say I can go in and play you send you
send you scores challenge you to matches
the thing with showcasing here at e3 is
battle ultimate and that's essentially
yeah we're using power-ups this time
range so it's a great leveler we've got
five types of power-ups you know cause
mayhem for it for you if I activate them
on you and there's a couple of defensive
ones as well so we're trying to bring
like ants a new way to play show you
it's a series that started in Russia and
had a Dutch gentleman common and and get
the right and now it's being developed
by a British man in San Francisco like
it's quite a hundred lost lots of other
interesting adventures in between
believe me yeah sure absolutely yeah but
anyway there there power-ups is very is
very smart yeah it will be a good
version because a lot subversion broke
up on on exactly this point on a really
laughs yes far really I hope they will
survive Hank you are you involved role
in this aria is someone writes somewhat
sorry yeah there's that there's that I
have a question for this guy do it yeah
so what why 60 and why not 120 frames
per second so um you know what you know
because well because because people do
the best players yes they'll complain if
it isn't 120 frames per second never
heard that I haven't heard that so yeah
are you hearing him now yeah okay Oh
Cheyenne I've seen so that when i get
back now I've seen seems like a fairly
straightforward thing you know it seems
a flat fairly straightforward yeah yeah
yes we'll listen to that song all I'm
gonna promise right I'll look into it
alright so the answer is yes i do get
involved I'll you know I fair I said
guys if they're Rambo if he's not at 120
p or what can you say to Tamara savoring
the second in 20 frames per second 1080p
4k okay go full-bore weird okay night I
can live with porque you know a couple
nobody has the poor game win but
everybody but they would if they knew
they could pay tax I guess yeah I think
we've got some b-roll as well actually I
want to see Tetris ultimate in a and in
all right here we go explain what's
happening here so this is a to lay
around and you know we've got one of the
really good player on the right there
and I think that's me yeah I started me
on the right and a very good play on
there so it's about the let it rain make
it rain which is one of our power ups
it's going to drop some garbage down on
us that's one of our power ups so else
is going on in yet t-spin double back
toggles on rushing me already doing all
under a singles so not free that said
that the mustaches there is hip to be
square which I've sent to him first
actually which is just a series of odo
pieces kind of trouble do you think i'll
ask great just flat surfaces no pain and
suffering horrible so very good yes and
like game over for me in about four
seconds single xing Alexi were you ever
able to play at the speed that some
people go I have a problem with console
good controls yes I'm or computer guy
but I can handle this Pete I I hope
after some practice yeah Hank what about
yourself oh yeah I have no problem on
the game boy version could you slam it
Sam pretty hard yeah so on the game boy
version their heart levels do you know
about the heart level I don't so if you
hurt if you push a certain combination
when you boot up the game you come to
the heart level okay the pieces are so
fast that you cannot reach the side of
the screen extend four blocks from the
bottom so it is it and so you're going
to feel because you can't reach out
there and then you basically if you can
make one Tetris you're the bomb but we
used to play that at CES past the game
around oh really it you know the game
only takes 10 seconds hey have you kept
coming to e3 urself Inc nope when was
the last time you were here I don't
remember at least 10 years really I had
what what do you think about the games
industry when you see do you think
there's it has become something
wonderful and new or do you think do you
look at it and are you a little bit
disappointed and then the way it's been
followed actually uh actually what I've
been seeing is great and we're moving
towards the movie industry hmm I mean
the quality of the intro movies that
I've seen in all the games
is like wow yeah and I just love that
part of the game excellent and I feel
that most of the game acquire more and
more culture which is also important
because before it was just funky funky
animations now it's much more so latent
that's great excellent well I think the
only way we could make this interview
any better because I'm in awe of meeting
you gentlemen especially you a dream
thank you is if we had some sort of a
cappella choir you should join us on
stage I think that would be I would that
would top this off perfectly can you
guys make that hanky can you make that
happen can it if you guys make I got
your hands can you can you make an a
cappella choir happen if you like just
like like that hands to get yet hey like
yeah I'm partner if we think one oh my
god that is probably my magic as if by
much it is amazing magic the power of
Tetris ultimus alright has brought I
think we have a let's all stand up let's
maybe as long as your head so I've got
taken off
do
amazing amazing Tetris ultimus coming to
xbox one thank you playstation 4 that's
a show and actually text so much an
absolute pleasure to meet you Hank same
to you and of course you will Adrian fit
and thank you wonderful choir that at
these gentlemen managed to create at of
thin air we're done here the game spot
III and stage 1 show is all done and
dusted thanks so much to everyone for
watching today and yes enjoy watching
all the stuff on gamespot com for it so
I'll show you III we gotta wrap up show
directly after this I'm off on my boy
all my Madhu's here to go play some
Tetris and learn how to sing hi